missile non guidés salir erratique
électron libre et le 100 libre
electronlibre ça veut dire si on traduit
hommes à conviction vrai mais comme ils
sont morts j'assume mes couettes un gir
1 par des gens qui veulent que des mecs
avec le doigt sur la couture du problème
si ce pays avait plus de gens aigris
conviction serait peut-être pas
exactement là où on en est et j'avais
fait que ne sachant pas j'ai beaucoup
traîné dans ma jeunesse j'étais très à
gauche
ouais je croyais à la révolution par le
tir mans oui et j'ai passé plusieurs
mois deux fois trois mois à pied en
amérique du sud sur les traces du che à
essayer de comprendre la révolution
permanente et tout et c'est pour ça
qu'on peut être jean survenu à midi à
copenhague qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater lors la vie personne
antarctique donc j'ai juste envie de
faire ce pourquoi je suis là je suis mon
destin ma mission je là j'essaye de la
remplir et quand je peux rendre service
à une personne ça me fait très plaisir
chercher une bière
les villes quoi aller voter non michel
drucker vous devez remercier ce sens qui
vous ne seriez pas là et bien ce soir je
vais remercier jacques chirac
ah oui qui m'a mis le pied à l'étrier
pour faire de la politique en france
voilà ah ouais ouais j'ai été son
conseiller sur les affaires
internationales et un jour j'ai dit que
je voulais députés mais dit il mais
visait une université un intello c'est
pas votre truc sinon en jeu quand même y
aller
et puis je les regardais faire et puis
j'ai tout appris grâce à lui donc s'il
ya quelqu'un à qui je dois rendre
hommage ce soir si le président cette
carte là elle est à vous